this morning we look at the long shadow
of fighting cancer specifically when it
involves children despite the federal
funding for cancer research only about
4% of it is set aside specifically for
childhood cancers the grim reality is
that 17% of kids diagnosed will not
survive Sunday mornings Lee Cowan takes
a look at the bond forged in the battle
between two families with a common enemy
- six year old hazel Hamersley her
make-believe restaurant hi how are you
was as real as ever we'd like to have a
table for two she seemed to us a kid
without a care in the world and for this
moment at least she was four years ago
hazel was diagnosed with neuroblastoma
one of the most common childhood cancers
she went through every round of therapy
you can imagine surgery chemotherapy
radiation therapy and doses of drugs far
larger than any small body should be
forced to endure but six months ago her
mom Lauren posted this the news explains
why hazel was in such a good mood she
played waitress for her mom and her new
friend Susan heard heard son David was
also diagnosed with neuroblastoma she
now travels the country helping to get
funding for childhood cancer research
and her bond with Lauren was almost
instant I think we can look in each
other's eyes and see the same the same
pain and the same hurt and the same
disbelief but we can also think see the
same joy and the same hope that we have
that things are getting better what you
go through as a parent with a child who
has cancer is traumatic on a number of
different levels it's not easy to get
through it and so when you meet another
family there's kind of this immediate
like yeah you get me you know what the
deal is
cheers to lunch
when David's neuroblastoma hit back in
2008 the survival rate was only about
one in three the odds weren't in his
favor and in 2011 at the age of only 10
he lost his battle when he was dying his
list of things for me to do in his
absence were to continue to advance
opportunities for research at least one
of the drugs David used in clinical
trials was later approved by the FDA
just in time to help hazel get through
some of her toughest moments did you
ever just get tired of going to the
hospital and tired of all these
treatments and tired of all the
medications yeah oh yeah and how did you
get through it all just by paying and
there is even more fighting ahead in
October hazel found out her cancer had
returned for the third time she's now on
a new drug in clinical trials the
doctors say he's promising thank you
this special soup the longer we can keep
a child like hazel here the research is
happening behind the scenes there's new
things coming out all the time and
there's so much exciting work being done
and so many advances but it has to be
fast enough you know to help hazel we
get to really enjoy everyday with each
other huh because we don't know what
tomorrow is gonna be thank you for the
opportunity to meet hazel what's really
sweet
two families one disease United in the
same fight cancer may rob a child of
their sense of invincibility to beat I
love you for CBS this morning Saturday
stay strong we counted Los Angeles